bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
donc coupe du monde 2010 est 16e de
finale nous voyons maintenant la partie
numéro deux de ces 16e de finale entre
maxime vachier lagrave et alexander hleb
d'hermann donc pas retenu dans la
première les namas n'a pas réussi grand
chose puisqu'en 24 coup la partie est
terminée par une nulle à noter la grosse
surprise quand même
il y en a eu plusieurs d'ailleurs
surprise dans ces 16e de finale mais la
grosse grosse surprise bien sûr c'est
l'élimination du champion du monde
magnus carlsen qui s'incline face à but
il n'a pas réussi à remonter la
situation après n'avoir obtenu que le
nul alors qu'il avait perdu donc la
première avec les noirs qu'avec les avec
les blancs puisqu'il est perdu avec les
blancs et donc il est éliminé manu ce
qu'arsène ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour maxime vachier lagrave ya d'autres
grands joueurs qui sont fils eminem est
sûr c'est très tendu cette coupe du
monde on y reviendra plus tard quand ça
sera un peu plus clair et on va
s'intéresser donc à cette deuxième
partie donc mon approche est maintenant
de la partie décisive de cette coupe du
monde de la qualification pour les
huitièmes de finale est en jeu ici là
cette fois je vous ai pas mis le
résultat de la partie
on va voir cette partie cruciale ici
même s'ils l'emportent bien sûr il
qualifié silène d'errements de l'import
tous les qualifiés donc c'est une partie
vraiment coupé et en cas de match nul
bien entendu on aura droit à des
partages dans ce match donc c'est parti
ici avec maxime qui enclenche avec tout
de suite eu quatre donc pour l'instant
ni varie pas trop ça nous verture ici
une car aucun que le propose lederman
avec ses six des 4 et le coût normal
dessin qu'on attaque au centre il ya
plusieurs coups possibles on peut jouer
cavalier en c3 pas en cas de prisons
reprendre cavaliers et maxime choisi
plutôt la barre en avance voilà un pouce
le pion ça permet au noir de sortir
leurs fous de cases blanches
c'est souvent ce que cherche à faire les
noirs avant de jouer le coup aussi s'il
aime bien pouvoir sortir leur fou c'est
pour ça que c'est c'est quand même
intéressant pour les noirs cette cette
variante
mais d'un autre côté les blancs en
bodiot de pions la centrale que n'ont
pas les noirs qu'elle est 3e 6 voilà
donc maintenant qu'on a je me 6 le fou
est sortie s'il était un ses 8 et bien
il serait fermée derrière ses propres
pions de une fois 2 et la maintenance et
celle d'oran 3 dans une type de
variantes
ça ressemble à la française c'est à dire
que on a bien la chaîne depuis au moins
ici la chaîne des pions blancs et les
noirs
avec ses 5 propose d'attaquer la base de
la chaîne et si le sur le point clé des
quatre ici est fou et 3 prises prise
cavaliers de cette petit rock calais c6
attention ça attaque le pion 5
il faut b52 maxime on rejoue une pièce
qui a déjà joué on a six prises ça va
les prendre et enfin de calais problème
c'est intéressant puisque après eux
prend f5 les noirs se retrouve avec un
pion isolé en dessert un pion ici doublé
f5 face à face à enfin sur mêmes
colonnes que f7 donc ça a l'air un
structurellement pas mal ceci dit comme
le pion et sur 15 mois on se fout sera
un peu bouchés par son propre pions mais
en tout cas c'est intéressant donc ici
ces trois de la part de maxime ça c'est
un coup aux responsables puisque ça rend
le pion aux 5
qu'est-ce qui se passe il faut regarder
si les noirs des prix le pion en scène
qu'ici quand même il y aurait fait il
fallait analyser ça simplement les
blancs répondu par food et 4 rebonds afu
des quatre qui attaquent le cavalier si
vous protéger par le fou simplement tour
et un clouage et si vous défendez par le
pion il suffit de jouer ensuite f4 qui
gagne une pièce mais là on aurait pu
revenir à la maison sans doute ici par
exemple par cavalier c6 tout simplement
échec au roi fou en recettes et
maintenant mesures pour parer échec mais
maintenant ça permet fou prendrait sept
avec
truc qui ont complètement à l'ouest
voyez que voilà donc en fête est à
l'initiative blanche où les noirs
raconte dumas la rocqué s'il joue il
faut s est alors un autre coup ci a
tenté c'est de jouer
roy 17 ici au 17 mai évidemment ça le
roi et des rockets ça fait quand même un
peu peur et il ya un très bon coup pour
les blancs ici c'est simplement de dames
b3 qui attaquent à la fois le club des
cinq et le pion bessette sur un des
rares possible comme moi c'est 8 protège
de tomber cette et maintenant la dame
protège desseigne mais la torah 8 elle
n'est pas près de sortir et le roi et
dans les courants d'air quand même mais
on voit bien que il a il a des problèmes
ici voilà foulée six attaques la dame et
les blancs ont une partie facile avec du
jeu facile ici c'est bon pour le blanc 7
cette ouverture donc après car l'épreuve
5.95 c3 est dangereux pour les noirs de
prendre au sein puisque ça ou à la
colonne ne tout simplement face aux en
noir fouet cette dame b 3 on peut donc
que la baronne combinois on profite du
fait que les noirs peuvent pas jouer
demba sy sall four et puis en plus on a
joué à 6 de toute façon il n'ya pas de
on n'est pas protégé
donc on attaque des scènes et bessède
surtout la cbc qui attaque et cabaye à 5
d'un bon coup ça permet de ne pas perdre
de temps le cas les protéger par la dame
il attaque la dame blanche et en même
temps ils protègent bessette et
maintenant dame ces deux très bons
pourquoi les blancs fait cette manoeuvre
pour qu'ils auraient pu jouer dames
c'est de tout de suite on a éloigné le
cavalier de des opérations mais se caler
à s'inquiétait beaucoup parce qu'il perd
pas de temps sur l' attaque du pion mais
maintenant on a un problème sur le pion
au f5
voilà et s'ils ont le temps qu'on défend
de ça on a un câble et noir qui est
hors-jeu dame 17 et les blancs finissent
leur leur développement par khalid et de
calais c4 de la part des noirs attention
ça attaque le fou 3 simplement tour qui
ne perd pas de temps ce fou est
potentiellement un peu un peu mauvais
puisqu'il va être bloquée par son propre
opinion
bon c'est un peu délicat mais on donne
le fou éventuellement menwar préfet ne
préfèrent échanger justement
alliée dans prend maintenant dans le six
tout simplement en cas d' attaque sur le
pion des scènes simplement de pouvoir
jouer tour tour des huit tours à des
hommes tour des huit exactement ce qui
se passe est maintenant enfin fou
j'essaye ne vous prends d'en prendre
et enfin pour l'épauler noir enfin le
petit rock
non mais non toujours un pion isolé en
dessert et des pions doublet comme un
oeil à un trait jir avantage blanc là
ici yep avantages matériels mais
structurellement c'est quand même un peu
mieux
donc les blancs profite h4 on enlève les
maths du couloir maintenant il y aura
plus de mal du couloir le roi sera
capable de sortir en h2 en cas d'échec
très loin dans la partie plus tard mais
en finale c'est important de garder ce
coup mais en même temps on menace de on
gagne un peu de l'espace allèles dames
avec ceux qui auront 1 h 4 h six
attaques la dame sa mère 4 et tour ses
huit intéressant il mange ou précis el
natour a fini son travail va sur la
colonne c'est qui permet d'avoir
peut-être une case en c4 ici peut-être
ça va jouer avec b 5e b 4 essayer
d'affaiblir et l'autre tour peut
remplacer en défense en des huit dames
f3 attention à ces attaques le pion tour
des 8es maintenant tour des quatre les
blancs mieux le bien sûr doubler les
tours ici pas retourné 1
donc les noirs voilà je vous le simple
tour c4 est je pense un très bon coup
les nordmann peut-être un peu délicat ce
qu autour des 4 d'ailleurs pour ça
puisque ça attaque le pion h4 voilà la
terre qu'on peut pas enlever la tour
sinon il y aurait prise du père du
curage 4 est peut-être ce couac l'a
finalement et du coup il est un peu près
si c'est possible comme des trois tours
prend d'un prend les noirs ont éliminé
une paire de tours il reste des pièces
des pièces lourdes on voit la tour huit
tours 8 on peut pas jouer tour d un
sinon sans doute les noirs freine ans
on y sème tout simplement au tour 3 pour
mac simon on monte la tour d'un cran
comme ça elle peut coulisser un peu ici
voir plus tard si on joue ces 4 ou 6 6
si la bcn bk tienne échange elle peut
coulisser de l'autre côté on tue non
plus tard en tout cas en 3 l'a un peu
plus de jeu que l'on veut plus de plus
d'opportunités h5 en bloc le pion ici le
pion un pion à claques pourquoi pas
j'ai trois des scènes qui se voit là ça
y est un an qu'on consolide encore un
peu plus la case c4 pour les noirs tour
des 3 d'un prend et simplement regarder
une petite astuce de maxime tour 3 et
wii on revient si vous faites dans le
programme il y aura tour échec d'abord
en faux par l échec et ensuite on
prendra gagné donc le seul coup c'est
d'amener huit mois la nuit échec d'un
prend et après d'un pro f celle des
scènes pardon f4 des noirs les noirs se
séparent de leurs pions doublé au bon
moment pile au bon moment f4 ils n'ont
pas peur du coup suivant de maxime qui
fait je prend 1,4 et qui propose nul
dans cette position mais oui parce que
regarder le roi blanc là il s'est trop
faible sincère que si la dame essayer
d'aller grappiller les pions là il y
aura un échec perpétuelle facile à
monter contre le roi blanc il y aura pas
moyen d'en sortir la dame noire en plus
aura là la possibilité de venir en g4
grimpe les noirs ici aurait pu jouer
sans doute le coup peut-être d'un
mauvais ou même d'un peu de son âme de
qui protège le pion h scène et qui
menacent sont déjà un échec en g4 qui
ramassent walker f4 sur les puristes car
voilà donc ici en plus ça attaque le
cube et deux bons et blanc vont prendre
là nul ici certainement
donc voilà le parti finalement un peu
terne rapidement joué bon maxima pas dû
trouver exactement ce qu'ils cherchaient
dans cette partie il s'est fait
surprendre par les nordmann qui démontre
qu'il est en forme à cette coupe du
monde je vous rappelle qu'il a quand
même éliminé un très fort joueur au
premier tour à 2700 points hainaut
et que pour l'instant il continue son
petit bonhomme de chemin ben deux
parties nulles sait rien et bien sûr
rien n'est joué
maxime a toutes ses chances mais sur
ventes d'armes des partages il est
toujours favori de ce match
mais tout reste à faire et donc la
grosse poubelle c'est l'élimination de
magnus carsen qui aujourd'hui n'a pas pu
faire mieux donc parties nulles après
donc avoir perdu le match aller hier il
est donc éliminée de cette coupe du
monde et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour maxime pour tenter de se qualifier
en finale et d'obtenir son ticket du
coup pour le championnat du monde le
prochain championnat du monde qui est en
cours de préparation voilà merci de
m'avoir suivi sur des monades tva la
prochaine mais sur des deux mains
toujours sauter bonal tv.com bien
entendu sur le site internet vous aurez
toutes les news
n'hésitez pas pourvoir se départagent
est aussi revoir et bien les tout c'est
tout et interview d'un gène 2017 ou le
championnat de france rapide féminin
qu'on a qu'on appuie entièrement filmé à
villandry 2010 est aussi ça vaut le coup
de revoir ça c'est vraiment très très
beau tourner on s'y rendre ah oui merci
de m'avoir suivi
à bientôt sur des modèles tv globo